guck mal meine stimme ist so weg ich
kann nicht mehr so heulen so hoch weiß
ich kann ja mal versuchen nun ton zu
singen er wollte was gelaufen jetzt
willkommen bei neuen video ich bin auch
bald wieder hier manchmal vielleicht ein
bisschen an meine stimme oder was heißt
ein bisschen ich bin eigentlich schon
ziemlich krank ich war nämlich eine
woche in österreich wenn ski gefahren
habe ich kräftig amüsiert und das ist
jetzt bei rumgekommen ohne scheiß bin
eben auf gestand ich wollte
sprachnachricht machen ging nicht da kam
nichts raus ich habe jetzt eigentlich
nur diesen blauen bonbons zu verdanken
dass ihr mich jetzt verstehen können ich
dachte wirklich das ist das erste mal
dass du kein youtube video drink hat
weil du einfach nicht reden kannst es
ging nicht auf jeden fall macht das
jetzt mit diesem hustenbonbon dann geht
das auf jeden fall klar ist jetzt
eigentlich auch scheißegal wir wollen
gar nicht lange anfangen direktor mit
dem thema an und zwar habe ich vor zwei
wochen so ein video gemacht wobei jungs
lügen das ist auch ganz cool weil ich
angekommen ich hab mich aufgefordert jo
schreibt darum als mädchen eure meinung
ein wobei ihr mädchen immer liegt das
habe auch wirklich ganz viele von euch
gemacht ich habe mir ein paar coole
dinge rausgesucht ich werde das jetzt
gleich mal ein bisschen vorlesen
kommentieren und so ich hoffe das kann
ich ganz gut rüberbringen und sagt dann
einfach mal so meine meinung dazu was
mich daran so stört und was ich auch
verstehen kann und da ist nur meine
meinung dass er wenig halt immer mal
wieder jetzt hier könnt natürlich unter
dieses video weitere dinge schreiben
wobei ihr mädchen immer liegt ihr
schlinge und ja wenn ihr bock ab mache
ich jetzt dann auch noch eine zweite
folgen die einfach nur noch nach oben da
lassen jetzt an dieser stelle oder
halten dass nach dem video glaube schon
wieder zu lange wir fallen direkt an mit
lüge nummer eins okay leute wir fangen
an ihr könnt ja auch immer als kommentar
schreiben was ihr von dieser lüge hat
stimmt das oder sagt die neuen das
stimmt gar nicht das hat sonnenschein 23
heißt viel falsch rübergebracht also ich
denke jedes mädchen lügt wenn sie einen
junge fragt wie viel sie wiegt also ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob es immer so ist aber
ich denke die meisten schulen also wenn
man als mädchen gefragt wird helfers auf
wer bist du denn im moment mal
eigentlich sagt man doch so als junge
fragt man mädchen ist nicht so nach
ihrem gewicht weil das das macht man
einfach nicht so finde ich denn du
kannst du nicht einfach franjo so
indirekt bist du fett oder bist du nicht
feld oder was ich auch ganz schlimm
finde dass zum beispiel jetzt bei
last.fm oder wie der ganze scheiß heißt
wer meine frage bekommt ja ich bin ein
meter 66 wie ihr 52 kilo ist das okay
oder ist das zu viel so was er denke
wieso fragst du mich so waßmann
seid ihr zufrieden fertig was ich dazu
sagen kann klar ich kann total verstehen
wenn man jetzt von einem jungen gefragt
wird sowie schwer bist du ich weiß es
sich also ich würde sowas ich würde
seine frage gar nicht stellen was juckt
mich das dann ist doch eigentlich total
irrelevant aber klar so sind dann halt
die meisten mädchen die dann glaub ich
weg wahrscheinlich zwei kilo zu viel
ich sag jetzt einfach mal dass und das
ich kann diese lüge irgendwie
nachvollziehen auch wenn mich jetzt
mädchen fragen würde wie schwer bist du
dann würde ich schon die wahrheit sagen
das ist schwer das ist schwer keine
ahnung da sind dann halt jungs und
mädchen wirklich unterschiedlichen aber
leute seid mit euch selber zufrieden
ihr seid so wie ihr seid ein faktor ist
faxe universe ok nächste lüge kommt von
millionen sie sagt mädchen lügen
eindeutig wenn ein junger sie fragt wen
sie verknallt ist da sagen mädchen immer
dass sie gerade niemand verliebt sind
bei mir es ist derzeit so dass ich es
jedem erzählen würde weil ich es ihm
schon erzählt habe leider steht ja auch
meine bf bf bf beste freundin wbf bin
ich jetzt rat um bff beste freundin best
besteht bff schreibt in die kommentare
ich weiß es gerade nicht beste freundin
wäre das einzige was mir jetzt einfallen
würde auch wenn das jetzt ja gut egal
wir belassen das erstmal auf jeden fall
kann ich dazu sagen dass wenn jetzt als
mädchen nicht so sagen wollt in wenige
verliebt zeit das ist bei jungs doch
genauso ich meine ich gehe doch nicht zu
viel auf meiner klasse hält ich stehe
gerade auf die schon teil
ich stehe gerade auf die man die person
also da steht er nicht alleine da
behaltet das für euch geht auch niemand
was an außerhalb wirklich eure besten
freundinnen und fertig kommen wir auch
schon zur dritten lüge und zwar kombi
von vanessa bach sie sagt wenn mädchen
sagen ich bin voll hässlich meinen sie
das nicht so sie sagen das nur um die
bestätigung der anderen zu bekommen dass
sie nicht hässlich sind weil sie dann
sagen nein du bist verliebt
das stimmt da gebe ich dir voll recht
das sagen ich fühle mich loco ich bin
wieder so höflich und die wissen genau
ich bin geiste person dieser welt das
ist auch übertrieben aber sie wissen
genau wo ich bin sooo geil alter jeder
junge will ich mir das führen wir jetzt
nicht weiter aus auf jeden fall
ich verstehe mich da eigentlich nicht
obwohl vielleicht auf der einen seite
auch schon ich meine jeder mensch findet
es schön bestätigung zu bekommen das man
geil ist dass man der king ist so wie
ich meine
nicht gucken meine stimme ist so weg ich
kann nicht mehr so hoch weiß ich kann ja
mal versuchen nun ton zu singen auf
jeden fall ich kann es verstehen wenn
die bestätigung braucht und sucht und
haben wollt allerdings reduziert dass in
einem gewissen maß kommen wir auch schon
zu wenigsten lüge und zwar kommt die von
powerlink mädchen lügen eindeutig wenn
die sagen ich brauche nur noch fünf
minuten ach so jetzt verstehe ich dass
sie sagen ey ich brauche nur noch fünf
minuten dann bin ich angezogen und
geschminkt ich glaube das ist jetzt kein
großes geheimnis dass da jedes mädchen
lüge ich mein wenn man das schafft in
fünf minuten dann ist mein mädchen das
ist glaube ich echt so also wenn man
unter fünf minuten sich duschen kann
schminken kann sich anziehen anziehen
geht ja auch so aus das ist höchst durch
das ziehen wir nicht an das tutorial ist
vielmehr auch nicht an
oder dass hier auch nicht an und was ist
das hier viel schweiß das team erst
richtig an
weil ich hab gar nichts zum anziehen und
der kleiderschrank ist dann so fällt der
platz fast da ja so seid ihr das weiß
ich ganz genau das weiß ich ganz genau
auf jeden fall die noch ein paar mehr
liegen parat ich wird allerdings sagen
ich muss das video jetzt noch schneiden
und das kommt ja schon in drei stunden
ich meine es ist schon drei oder so auf
jeden fall wenn es euch gefallen als
enorm nach oben da für zweiten teil auf
jeden fall den stadtkern ab blabla
ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste woche
halt am dienstag und am donnerstag
wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwann abends
jetzt kommen wir mal zwei videos in der
woche und am wochenende also drei in der
kompletten woche ins tor am start war
das angewendete oben links geht es doch
weiter mit meinem letzten you das war
ich habe meinen sixpack gezeigt leute
wir sehen uns dann halt am dienstag ist
jetzt ok alex haut rein
ciao